to bring in Tom Izzo the head coach
Michigan State House the voice coach
voice is great but I can't believe
you're turning into one of those
analytic guys that you're gonna you know
99 means you lose 101 means you win you
don't really believe in all that deal
yes I do the team with the most points
always wins coach that's a good point
now I got agrium at ok do you use
analytics at Michigan State you know we
do but I think it's I you know I mean
but this guy we're going to talk about
I'm not sure what it past all the
analytics tests if you look at it
sometimes you gotta you gotta look at a
guy's heart you gotta look at a day you
know some guys are winners some guys
aren't there's a lot of different things
but analytics can play a part but I
think sometimes in NBA Annabelle was
growing so much the analytics that we
get guys like you then start talking
about how you win a game not scary told
me who helped me with draymond Green
with his approach to the game
competitiveness was this on display at
Michigan State you know damn he I mean
he's always been a very passionate guy
you know and I mean let's face it we all
you and me included because I know both
of us um get to the point where you're
always getting right up to that line I
think guys that are great coaches I
think I've gone through a lot of great
coaches and dealt with some here in our
state like back when I was growing up
both sham buckling I did he crossed the
line did woody hayes cross the line you
know and we are in a different era right
now I think that's the hardest part you
know is everybody's trying to adjust to
the new era and I think dream on I took
a hundred remnants you know I'd rather
coach him down a little bit on his
passion enthusiasm and will to win than
trying to coach him up to that but we
all do got to find that fine line and
learn how to walk it and that's kind of
what he'll do he's really a smart kid I
believe it or not a really smart kid but
we can look at one man's passion
our competitiveness is another man's
dirtiness you know and there there's a
fine line in what we see with draymond
Green yeah you know I don't know you
know I looked at the noni series was of
course the Yokohama city and you know I
mean I watched a thousand videos on
under my you know he does he does kick
his legs it's been well well documented
but was it on purpose or not you know
personally I would doubt it i never saw
that part of him we all do some dumb
things if he did in the moment of
competition but i don't look at him as a
dirty player never have felt he was a
dirty player and effectively get the
norm an incredible incredible guy
talking to Tom Izzo Michigan State head
coach joining a stamp Patrick show I I
love the passion I love the way place I
think he's the team MVP I just think
that he gets himself he got himself in
this position where you left it to
somebody else to decide your fate for a
game and that's a big mistake on his
part you know can't get me all that he
came back to that point yeah that's a
thursday night i think he put himself in
the houston game when I had nothing to
do that last second you know and I don't
even know if that was I think they were
intentionally trying to follow and you
know and it got carried away so nice and
you get something against you a
technical error flagrant against you but
you know there's very few sports that's
one thing hard about basketball there's
very few sports in football you can hold
50 times and you get penalties but you
don't get ejected in other games you
same way in basketball you know we got
the five or six fall depending whether
you're in college or pro and at the
affection and in this case they have a
rule that you know what he did for
syriza goes affects this one and you
know I get it I get the fact that
accumulation sometimes but boy when
you're planning the finals as tough to
swallow and yet or you could argue and
say well he should have been more on
topic I didn't think the last thing was
his warrant at his other thing
if you looked at it but then again I
think he's going to grow from this learn
from this and I think we all learned how
valuable he is to that team you know
there's not many guys that can do as
many things as he does I mean he doesn't
shoot like curry doesn't rebound like
Rodman he doesn't you know do this like
this guy doesn't you know pass like
magic but he's he can do all those
things so well and I think last night
you saw were defensively in his
communication he can help for other guys
become better than they may be really
are in a defensive end and I think
offensively he's got a tremendous
basketball IQ and everybody looks at it
as offensive thing and I look at it as a
defensive thing I still go back to you
possibly coaching the cavs and you would
have had the opportunity to coach LeBron
now how real was that possibility well
Dan Gilbert is you know Michigan State
guy and a great guy and you know would
have been a guy that I definitely could
have worked for I'll tell you that he he
impressed me on the interview I'm just I
guess I'm just a college guy but of some
of the jobs that I've had a chance to go
to that was one that definitely
intrigued me the most just because of
the way Dan was in his passion for
winning and I thought he was going to
run a good organization and was there
little offer uh you know we talked
seriously yeah and but it was you know
right when LeBron was making that
decision to go to Miami and so was kind
of a turbulent time in a way it was a
week before that is a little bit crazy
and a lot on no one's that's for sure
did you know LeBron was not going to
stay there for that's why he didn't take
the job no I I didn't know that I you
know I talked to some of his people that
I knew and had recruited him a little
bit when he was a freshman in high
school and decided this is a waste of
time if you run and coach if you knew
LeBron was staying in Cleveland would
you have taken that job so I love about
you Dan you always ask the great
questions um what put it this way I
think anybody would would be in full
a little more by arguably one of the
greatest players ever played a game so
but I was really intrigued by that job
the treatment was in Dan Gilbert and I
thought what he wanted to do there and
whether whoever he had but let's face it
LeBron James is LeBron James and I don't
know I don't know thats quiet didn't
happen so I don't know how that sounds
like an answer that sounds like yes that
sounds like he is but I didn't know he
wasn't going either I didn't know he was
leaving yeah but that's got to be the
first thing that you want to find it
okay when did you find out LeBron was
going to Miami uh on his announcement on
that on this way oh yes we're to god
swear to know oh yeah well how could I
find out any other way you think he
called me up and legend now if you're
looking at the job when you call up
LeBron and say hey I'll be your coach I
just need to know that I'm gonna be your
coach here in class oh and you think he
was gonna tell me that a week before huh
yeah I appreciate how highly you think
but I gotta tell you're certifiably are
you getting in trouble you doing
anything over the summer is there any
fun happening you know been traveling a
lot actually yeah you know I've gone on
to Cleveland gone out to Golden State
I've had a couple of nice things don't
kill I've been traveling a little more
than normal but we start camps today
here we are freshmen are in so it's kind
of been a fun time around here and
especially with all the controversy now
keeps you a little busy but hey
everybody got what they want they're
going to get a hell of a serious who
knows what is going to be so we'll we'll
find out i think it's going to be an
incredible series but I I will say this
you know that was the saddest day for
draymond I mean it was a tough day you
know sunday and monday and i think he so
maybe he'll still have a chance to play
for a championship now and did you talk
to him oh yeah i think it would have
gave up his right and left arm to play
in that game and all the money he's made
which would it hurt me because I summer
that's going to the user requirements so
want to make sure he doesn't give up too
much but I think you want to give up a
lot dan I mean you know what people
don't understand about the kid is he's
you know people talk about all the
different things whether you're tough
whether you're good with III could sum
him up in one word is he's just a winner
you know he does winning is important
and and you might say well then why
would he do something or why would he
put himself in that position part of it
is to you know he's 25 or 6 years old
and he's he's kind of taken on a new
Fame year ago he's making eight nine
hundred thousand then he signs an 85
million dollar contract and you know
he's adjusting but he's so smart he'll
adjust and he'll be fine I uh have fun
this summer the rest of that ruin your
day no no no why I'm dead kid no no I i
think if you'd said i was taking the job
in Cleveland but LeBron told me that he
was going to Miami then we could have
made some headlines here why are you so
selfish think of me coach you were never
hate you Blaire right I love anybody
that graduates some date barely did you
do graduate yes I did graduate oh yes I
did barely sorry I'm treated yeah Thank
You coach hey you have a great summer
due to clocking in all right nobody
that's Tom Izzo Michigan State head
coach the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience